bonjour à la pollution
alors une dirigeons vers la digue
temporaire on a sacrifié la rue ici pour
monter une digue
alors les camions à 100 mille tonnes de
pierres qui a été livrée ici plus on va
avancer plus il va y avoir de l'eau si
avant c'était tout c'était tout inonder
ici c'est oui oui oui oui et alors juste
tout ça ça a été rajoutée tout au moins
quand vous regardez où le pavage termine
s'était pas vu ici là mais c'est
aberrant tous ces gens là
malheureusement nous n'aurons pas de
fond pas que c'est à leur propriété
c'est dommage mais continue de pomper
chez vous
oui alors comme vous pouvez voir en
action chez eux quand même honnêtement
oui je comprends ne vous avait pas
d'électricité vous avez nos potable
c'est non vous savez que vous êtes dans
la zone évacuée
bon courage regardez ça incroyable est
ce que je peux vous dire que c'est la
première fois que je viens jusqu'ici
vous le voyez en même temps que moi
voyager j'ai vu des photos aériennes
mais non quelle désolation
yes là où est ce qu'on vit ici
ici on est au bout la rue et c'est notre
station de pompage
c'est incroyable parce qu'on a travaillé
travaillé les bénévoles ont travaillé
tout le monde a travaillé pour rehausser
la digue pour arriver à parce qu'on nous
annonce un mois l'a dit qu'elle est
bonne pour 25 mètres au dessus du niveau
de la mer elle était pour 25
il ya des endroits où elles s'étaient
légèrement affaissés on appris le
rapport des experts les expertises qui
nous ont fait et on a décidé que tous
les endroits qui était plus critique
parce qu'il n'avait pas le 25 on ya en
priorité rehausser sa après sont heureux
aussi pour prévoir une plus grosse crue
et puis on était prêt à en avoir plus et
c'est la digue qui a flanché
donc y'a plus personne qui est vraiment
protégé avec les changements climatiques
avec non la réelle nouvelle réalité dans
laquelle au nom de tous c'est pour ça
que nous on avait demandé à la russie
parce qu'on savait que on a vu 2010 est
ce que ça allait donner
on y danse aisément dans la rue aussi
non
de pied trop tard patientez arrive sur
le nez lumière on est désolé monsieur
bonjour
ok merci bien merci alors c'est ça qui a
cédé oui il sait comment ça commence à
se penser alors il ya eu une première
fissure et après à cause de la pression
de l'eau ici et qu'il n'y avait rien là
ben ça toute la pression ça ouvre parce
que blum comme ça c'est la force de
l'eau c'est incroyable et c'est un fait
en sorte que l'on a le lac des deux
montagnes cet angle ça complète
complètement le lac des deux montagnes
s'est retrouvé dans cette partir de là
c'est incroyable quand même à la forme
de l'eau oui ces gens ici qu'il a fallu
évacuer au plus vite
c'est pas les maisons qui vont pouvoir
être réhabilité
non honnêtement je crois pas que c'est
récupérable
donc vous pensez encore qu'une digue
c'est la meilleure solution parce qu'on
parle de plus en plus de laisser plus de
2 libre cours aux cours d'eau en fait un
peu plus de liberté pour les cours du
jeu suis d'accord avec ça mais est-ce
que vous allez prendre cinq mille
personnel ou c'est le nombre de maisons
touchées c'est presque 3000 maisons
est-ce qu'on va prendre trois mille
maisons puis leur dire de déménager tout
presque impossible à imaginer c'est
incroyable des gens à un bon la maison
modulaire leur appartient le terrain ne
leur appartient pas ici mais ces gens
alors
il ya des gens arrêtent des retraités
n'ont pas les moyens d'aller s'acheter
aux jo pour les moyennes et les
nouvelles mesures que monsieur legault
le premier ministre a annoncé en disant
peut-être 200 mille dollars si jamais
vous avez des prêts à déménager
vous envisagez pas cette solution là en
ce moment la paix si quelqu'un veut le
faire célébrer eux de le faire donc vous
votre priorité à partir de maintenant
qu'est ce que c'est pour sécuriser les
lieux pour que tout le monde puisse
réintégrer
oui il faut faire un gros ménage je suis
entièrement d'accord je fais partie de
ceux qui vont avoir le gros ménage et
démolition ça va prendre des années mais
vous avez l'énergie pour le faire
oui pourquoi pas non parce que certains
pourraient être découragés en voyant ça
mais vous n'avez pas le droit j'imagine
mais oui on peut avoir un moment dany
doré ou c'est lourd mais non non il faut
selon vous serez les manches sont un peu
de colonne vertébrale go on part je
préfère partir je laime la maison moi
j'adore ma maison est ce que je vais
laisser tomber non non alors on va
sécuriser les lieux on va faire en sorte
qu'on peut se continuer de vivre
sainte-marthe-sur-le-lac et d'être
heureux